come back to las vegas now if you're
looking for a quick easy and affordable
dish to make for dinner
smith's chef jeff jackson has the
perfect recipe
here's a look hello everybody i'm chef
jeff from smiths
okay one of my favorite ingredients at
the meat department at your local smiths
is this beef shaved steak i love this
stuff and it's fairly cheap
and there's a pound of it but you can
make a million things with it just think
steak and cheese and that's what i think
and you can use that for this we're
gonna make steak and cheese pull-aparts
really easy really fun let's get right
to it okay
so what i did earlier is i browned that
steak with some
onions and garlic and salt and pepper so
that's what i have right here
all ready to go for me and then what i'm
going to do to make these pulled parts
is just use
regular biscuit dough you go to the
freezer or refrigerator section at your
local smiths
so and whenever i do this it's funny
because my dog will hear the pop and
always run and hide
and i think it surprises me every time
too but yeah just that little pop
always gets them it's kind of funny okay
so there's eight pieces in here this is
going to make
16. so now you want to buy the flaky you
need to buy the flaky because there's
layers
so we're going to turn these eight
pieces into 16 pieces so if you just
grab it right in the middle
separate it like so you have two pieces
okay let's build one
i like to do this in a um cast iron
skillet works really good the size is
perfect so you're going to want to
either butter it or oil it or something
just give it a good grease all the way
around
like so and then let's build one so what
i'm gonna do
is take some cheese this is american
cheese that i've sliced into fourth so
get nice slices like that just put a
slice of that onto each one of these
maybe stretch it out a little bit
and then take some of our steak mixture
put on top
like so and then we're just going to
fold the dough right around it almost
like you're making a dumpling or
something like that but you just
wrap it around there pinch it into a
nice lovely little roll like so
do it like that and i'll do it again now
16 will fit in a 10 inch cast iron pan
perfectly
so you just do this with all 16 you may
end up with a little bit extra filling
but
what's the harm in that right so we make
all of our 16 rolls
that's what i have right here and so
what i do at this point
is then i would just take and brush
butter on the whole thing like so
one of the things i really love too and
it's popular these days is
everything bagel spice you can find this
in the the spice aisle at your local
smiths
just sprinkle some of that on there have
your oven preheating to
450 no it's 375. it's not so hot
so let's get this in the oven let's see
the one that i finished see how we did
so in goes that out comes our done one
and that looks awesome look at that
our steak and cheese pull-aparts let me
put it on the
plate like that maybe sprinkle some more
butter on there at the end
but that is it guys super easy
i'm not going to open up because i want
it to be a surprise
my guest thinks it'll be a roll but it's
a steak and cheese roll super delicious
super easy
of course you can find all these
ingredients your local smiths thank you
so much for watching
and thank you for shopping we'll see you
next time bye-bye
that's my kind of food right there i'm
telling you to get the full recipe and
for more information you can visit
smithsfoodanddrug.com